podcast man we have got the homie
repping the DMV in here Garrett zukis
welcome sir yes sir bro well before we
have you uh get to the bars man just
kind of give a little rundown of what
you got going on give a little
background about yourself uh [__] I'm
from the DMV area Northern Virginia I'm
not far from DC
um I've been rapping since I was a
little kid I lived in La three years now
um the last couple years been dope a lot
of momentum feel you know we started our
own little wave and stoked to be up here
before you rap what are your like three
biggest influences hip-hop wise
um
um Mac Miller
Drake
and
I don't know the people around me the
people around you yeah Casey Manheim
Casey yeah there you go well let's see
how that goes shout out to Casey oh wait
I'm sorry
queso okay so in the building yes sir
Caso is here all right look man uh you
got a new song Lemon Cherry out uh yeah
new to to uh two song project Lemon
Cherry uh blunt guts and Lucid uh the
track name okay and then you have a weed
of your own sorts yeah we're uh we're
working on the Lemon Cherry strain as
well my favorite strain can I understand
the theme of the project yeah uh where
can they follow you man uh get a zukis
everywhere two hours two T's and
z-o-u-k-i-s there it is man let's get to
them bars bro let's do it
mama told me do it big boy I always been
an outcast can't wait for the day that I
could tell her where the house at stress
blocked success find a way around there
wake up hit the wood first I call that a
bounce pass the same eyes that they
slept on me with now they wired at the
kid on some ecstasy [__] cold quests
through my veins they injected me with
different hits today perfected the mix
now look how Legend is this still
independent No Label peeled off murder
whip is so fatal I've been sick I'll be
dripping like post nasal rappers five
six why they picks from low angles I
don't know no Angels I'll be with the
Sinners and singers getting dollars
causing different dilemmas all these La
girls cold but it really isn't making me
shiver east coast boy tell me how to
live with the winners had to get out of
the city and get some different
experience smoking all day getting
higher the helium yeah little man you
tearing I be burning down the block like
why so serious G on a bottle like a
Gatorade logo sending drunk texts and
she never say no though and she always
bring a friend it's a BOGO and she wanna
[__]
[Music]
Shorty's fighting over me but like Kill
Bill it's still chill it's still true
the [__] got a Holyfield it's real deal
some wounds heal but there's others I
still feel imma leave my kids a sick
amount no ill will yeah I'm with bootleg
curve she got a fat ass and a cute face
Kev I caught the neck can I get a hooray
Kev I loved it yesterday it's a new day
cap I just got back from where to tag on
my suitcase says big bad got me fighting
in a new way class my game plan really
looking like a doomsday map now they got
me charged up saying Zoo ain't gas look
I need 20 M's and Alex Earl to spend it
with been in Corners in the Benz with my
friends who've been around but for
benefits feel like Brad in this Coop I'm
Limitless throw up VA till you sick of
it need a leave she do me first like
parentheses she undercover switching up
her identity [__] eating up the
pedigree
yeah and I'm not getting your message
I'm in Scottsdale [__] up 11 11
shorty mouth open more than a 7-Eleven
you gotta watch who you getting in bed
with now go for business and women I'm
living in a glitch in the system
diamonds scatter in the light like a
prism no math class why they preaching
division godspeed this divine
intervention yeah
in north VA it was colder days bowling
games had the sauce since the throwaways
in this G-Wagon skate like some
rollerblades hanging out the truck like
Billy Mays Willie Mays I'm making plays
I'd rather burn out and fade away it's
pay to play if you want to be in my day
today faded Shades my Men In Black like
Agent K I'm living dreams for all the
nights I stayed awake heavily sedated
haven't got a wait list don't know if
imma make it I'm checking my application
if I don't I guess it's back to the
basement I make up with the talent when
I'm lacking in patience blazing getting
hot got me seeing mirages ghosts in my
past and others in the garages been in
the field I'm with a couple Natasha's do
this in my sleep I should have worn my
pajamas bootleg cab I used to Bootleg
CDs add an extra point like I'm scoring
a TD now it's baddies on the bottle
rubbing me like genies and they [__]
ASAP like Riri my [__] is tier one your
[__] is low level and when you make
waves that mean you won't settle I'm
finna [__] the world and I'm laying out
rose petals my name's stuck today tongue
like cold metal yeah good
I should have worn sunscreen I'm by the
pool getting slumped where the Draymond
Green not the quickest to the whole but
they're great on deep and I should have
known better [__] shame on me yeah your
desires gonna make you a servant
calculate it if I did it then I did it
on purpose maybe they not broke but they
really is broken put a battery in their
back and it still isn't working as far
as hours go there's 10K In the Flesh I
ride with Good Vibes the cambe and the
rest the blunt the sunset both taking my
breath make it really hard to stay with
my chest Yes you heard right all the
Romans are true the sign in the air is
not a usual mood all the problems on my
plate I just view them as food you're
watching the animal that's what you do
at the zoo let's get it
oh my God fire I'll go yo go follow this
guy right now Garrett zukus had to spell
your name again for this
g-a-r-r-e-t-t z-o-u-k-i-s oh my God that
was incredible let's [__] go man
thank you for the opportunity bro yes
sir
hey I know you just watched a new
freestyle guess what we're dropping them
every week sometimes more than once a
week Jesus we've been dropping a lot
lately uh shout out to LRG don't forget
go to
l-r-g.com use the promo code bootleg
save 30 off at checkout you get this
look at this jacket look at that lining
it's LRG baby 30 off this bad boy go to
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg and save 30
off at checkout and check out another
freestyle next week